do you have any fun stories of working
with Pedro Pascal and the Mandalorian no
I didn't work with Pedro I never saw
Pedro because Pedro there is an actor
and they're not going to put him in that
tin tin bucket and have him walking
around inside of that no it's of course
not would you do it again Su uh yeah of
course I would do it again because I
love I I love filon I love John um I'd
love to work with Rosario um the the
only issue if there's any issue that I
that I have is that when you do one of
those shows it's not real actor friendly
in the way of oh some guts here oh I get
to play like very calm and very well
it's like you know a line here and a few
lines there you don't go up here you
don't go down you know nobody's ever
accused me of being a subtle actor you
know